ganz wichtiger hinweis die heute schon
da sind wir sehr stolz drauf ist ab
sofort deutschlands erste zweig sendung
gehen sie also an den fernseher
übersicht zu hause und scannen sie jetzt
mit ihrem handy diesen qr code um
nachzuweisen dass sie geimpft sind oder
genießen ja ich würde auch wirklich
keinen druck aufbauen aber wenn nicht
explodiert in fünf sekunden ihr
fernseher ja sorry es geht nicht anders
die deutsche impfkampagne ist quasi ein
gepennt da
muss halt druck aufgebaut werden scheint
ein drittel der zuschauer verloren 20
millionen erwachsene deutsche die sich
impfen lassen könnten haben es noch
nicht gemacht wir verharren bei 62%
impfquote frankreich mal zum vergleich
frankreich startet derweil im technisch
richtig durch ja das ist auch kein
wunder drei gebe dabei denen mit dem
pastor sanitär regelrecht kontrolliert
und da haben sich millionen franzosen
eben doch noch impfen lassen es
funktioniert also und ist auch gar nicht
so kompliziert
also meine damen und herren 3g ist das
grundprinzip
3g 3gs
kind wieder neue songs von nena 3g 3g 3g
wann ich werde geändert und wenn das
nicht hilft dann kommt eben zweig in den
letzten 14 tagen hat sich die zahl der
cobit intensivpatienten bei uns fast
verdoppelt und sie werden jünger nicht
einmal lieber eine kneipe nur mit
geimpften und genesenen als der kneipe
die schon wieder dicht macht hier
vielleicht noch mal als hilfe und kleine
eselsbrücke wenn in einer bar zwei gilt
heißt das erz vorgeht so darf sich
drinnen die brille rostig saufen während
3gp und draußen vor der tür steht und
traurig guckt ja es wird ungemütlicher
für die ungeimpften im oktober geht es
für die lose mit dem test selber
bezahlen rein zufällig erst nach der
bundestagswahl
hat sich so ergeben immerhin haben sich
die gesundheitsminister diese woche nach
all dem chaos endlich auf eine
einheitliche quarantäne für schulen
geeinigt es müssen nicht mehr ganze
klassen 14 tage nach hause wenn einer
infiziert ist und zwar gilt das bei
schuh wo schulen wo regelmäßig getestet
wird wo wir eine gute durchlüftung haben
wo die aa
regel eingehalten werden gut wenn die
regeln nicht eingehalten werden brauchst
in jedem fall eine gute durchlüftung
seit dienstag dürfen arbeitgeber in
schulen kitas und pflegeheim ihr
personal nach dem impfstatus fragen
solange die pandemie anhält überfällig
wirklich überfällig meine datenschutz
ist sehr wichtig aber es gibt auch ein
grundrecht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
wobei in schulen braucht sie für so was
eigentlich kein gesetz erreicht doch ein
nerviges kind
[Musik]
nein ich bin nicht
ach ja kinder man bekommt so viel zurück
man ganz ernsthaft warum nur 62 prozent
impfquote warum hat ein produkt das
unter umständen mein leben rettet und
umsonst ist ein marketing problem kann
iwase ich behaupte
verschwörungstheoretiker querdenker und
co sind auch unter den ungeimpften nur
eine kleine minderheit
halt eine sehr laute minderheit mit der
zu diskutieren wirklich gar keinen sinn
mehr macht dass ein impfstoff der ist
entwickelt worden am computer wie soll
denn er gegen einen virus helfen die
noch niemand gesehen hat wie soll das
gehen es geht nicht
was man nicht sieht gibt es auch nicht
gehirnzellen zum beispiel wie kriegt man
solche leute zum impfen wie vielleicht
doch prämien oder
ich weiß nicht gutschein fürs
uhrengeschäft weiß es wirklich nicht man
ist nur noch müde wenn man denen zuhört
manches hin sich immer noch als
widerstandskämpfer gegen eine irgendwie
linke gesundheitsdiktatur
also da konnte man keinen unterschied
machen von reden von heutigen link
übersiedler damals geredet gewagter
vergleich mit gewagter vergleich
nein sie müssen die hitler mal anhören
ja das ein satz den man heute eher
selten hört sie müssen sich hitler mal
anhören erst habe ich über den man
gerade gelacht aber dann habe ich das
hier in unserem archiv gefunden wussten
sie dass hitler eins zu eins geredet hat
wie der drosten
leider leider ja ständig und ich wette
dass es auch in ihrem bekanntenkreis so
heißt es jetzt in dänemark macht alles
wieder auf ja aber mit 80 prozent
impfquote ihre chance bekommen vergesst
impfgegner totale zeitverschwendung man
muss die erreichen die einfach nur zu
bequem sind oder zu unorganisiert
niederschwellige impfangebot ja und zwar
viel viel mehr auf jedem marktplatz in
jeder fußgängerzone muss einer von
diesen in bussen stehen wo man ohne
termin hingehen kann nur so geht das
plus natürlich immer wieder informieren
manche leute sind eben auch verunsichert
durch
internet falsche freunde til schweiger
informieren für jeden verständlich um
nicht zu sagen kindgerecht fällt mir ein
kennen sie ja ich dieses wunderbare neue
buch der impfmuffel da geht es um ein
motto das sich partout nicht impfen
lassen will die erklärte er kam aus dem
info flog mal über 90 prozent der kuchen
intensivpatienten sind ungeimpft
verstehe ich nicht sagt der impfmuffel
oh mein gott du telegramm opfer der
arbeiten ist viel größer als der andere
verstehe ich mir gesagt der impfmuffel
und frisst die maus auf dann kriegt dann
darmverschluss rennt ins krankenhaus
weil da alle betten schon voll sind mit
anderen ungeimpften infos muss er dann
doch länger auf seine behandlung warten
ende
ja sollte man unbedingt vorlesen in
jeder deutschen grundschule und jeder
kita wie läuft es da eigentlich so
zurück aus den ferien mit diplom
pädagoge till reiners
[Musik]
kinder ferien vorbei kita und schule
gehen wieder los habt ihr bock
das wusste ich auch der fällt mir noch
ein bisschen noch letztes jahr als wir
aus dem sommer zurück kam und es gab
kaum luftfilter
vor genau dasselbe wie ihr seht schon
wieder passiert
alle sind voll wütend bloß weil man die
anträge für bundeszuschüsse zu filtern
erst seit den 27 august stellen kann
jetzt habe ich eine frage an euch wer
von euch hat den seiten so einen antrag
gestellt
siehst du mein reden fragt nicht was der
staat für euch tun kann sondern was er
für den staat tun könnt und da muss ich
leider sagen kommt echt wenig von euch
liebe kinder wer zahlt den steuern eure
eltern kümmern sich ums
wirtschaftswachstum während ihr nur mit
eurem eigenen wachstum beschäftigt seit
wahlbeteiligung der unter 18-jährigen
0% und dann wundert ihr euch kommen egal
das hightech-land deutschland hat doch
längst eine antwort auf die vierte welle
in klassenzimmern zu öffnen und wenn es
kalt wird dann greift eben wieder unsere
berühmte nationale wärme strategie und
man muss sich vielleicht wirklich ein
bisschen was für ärmere es noch zum
anziehen mitbringen vielleicht macht man
auch mal eine kleine kniebeuge oder so
oder klatscht in die hände damit man ein
bisschen warm wird
geklatscht ja gar nicht auch jetzt sieht
er wieder so eine schnute euro
gebrauchen gefilterte luft
oma da mission lieben ihre luft
gereinigt den meisten der erwachsenen
spendiert man auch keine teure
luftfilter
also außer jetzt im öffentlichen dienst
klar aber lieber dankbar dass diesen
herbst kitas und schulen in jedem fall
auf bleiben anderthalb wochen nach
ferienende waren in nrw bereits 30.000
18 schülerinnen und schüler in
quarantäne
präsenzunterricht
aber in quarantäne
im übrigen kinder haben noch ganz selten
schwere verläufe und noch weiß ja keiner
wie sich longo wird bei euch auswirkt
wartet doch einfach mal ab so gibt es
noch fragen an die kanzlerin
[Musik]
mein lieblings es ist das lieblingsessen
mein lieblingsessen ist spaghetti
bolognese
spaghetti mein gott da dürft ihr einmal
kritisch fragen dann kommt so eine
luftnummer
leute ganz was anderes wer hat lust auf
dem schönen pcr test
[Musik]
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten